[Musique]
il n'y a qu'une seule guerre qui compte et
c'est ici
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est accablant mais de la meilleure
façon possible un endroit où les gens peuvent
vraiment démontrer leur passion
[Musique]
pour  voir la joie que cela apporte
aux visages de tant de gens est incroyable, vous savez, mais
ils n'ont pas regardé s'ils n'étaient pas des fans,
nous n'aurions rien à faire, c'est notre
façon de dire merci si vous vous êtes
retrouvé sur le trône de fer quoi
serait la première loi que vous
adopteriez, les femmes pourraient être gentilles messieurs doivent
nettoyer leur propre lit puant il
y a un personnage qui nous adore n'avait pas été
tué qui aurait été J'ai vraiment
adoré travailler avec Jack Gleeson tellement
que j'ai  dire Joffrey
pour montrer fait par des adultes pour des adultes
et nous prenons des risques cette saison, en
particulier le genre de rassemblement de tout le monde pour
faire équipe contre la
menace imminente, vous pouvez sentir l'
élan créer beaucoup de choses qui arrivent
à la tête des
alliances sont forgées des alliances  sont en
train  g cassé, tout explose, ça
ne fera que s'agrandir et s'améliorer
[Musique]